hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well hey you know I've
got this question for you before you ask
us about what justice is he says you're
pretty rich you know that you're
well-off and you look around
nice house you know you put on dinner
parties and things like that is that why
you're so happy and kefla says well
that's a good question
a lot of people would say yeah I'm happy
because I'm well he asked them a few
other questions
where'd you money come from how did you
get it you know bless you you start out
rich and those are relevant too but the
big question is will money make you
happy
money is a good thing isn't it yeah what
happens if you don't have money you're
trying to get it why are you trying to
get
okay you need it yeah for for what I
mean you don't need it for it to get
somebody to love you to you and that's
nice but you know luckily we handle
everything all that what do you need it
for I look around the rooms but
everything you've got I think you've
purchased it well I'm saying right now
they're right while these desks are
purchased this blackboard is purchased
no money none of this this nice stuff of
course that's not enough to make you
happy by itself is it having a backpack
and choose money by haircuts too or you
know whatever other things you've done
with your body to make it the way you
want what else you need money for all
those are pretty important that they
especially you know in our society you
can live out of doors you can't live
without a car at a house and I don't
just mean renting or something like that
I mean like being a street person that's
not a very nice life as a there are some
people who take on that life voluntarily
but most people who who are in that
situation it's not voluntary and he's
actually talking about when you get
older it's nice to have money then -
isn't that if you don't have money if
you didn't put away in our society if
you didn't put away for retirement what
happens to you when you get old it's
pretty tough isn't it
if you have family and they'll take you
in then you might be okay if not you're
gonna have to find out how to make food
really cheap and find a place to live
you know
medicated Medicare mixed up which is the
one for
for impoverished people Medicaid or
Medicare no Medicaid that is for people
who are low income yeah
Medicaid you know it's not a lot of fun
when you get a doctor who has to file
Medicaid claims you may not get good
medical care because of it can't travel
can't you know go where you want to
unless somebody else provides these
things so you know wealth does seem to
be pretty important will wealth make you
happy by itself why not here's an
interesting thought experiment to think
about think about the people that you
care about there's probably more than
one right I know for all of you now
think about a big amount of money let's
let's make it ten million dollars cuz
million dollars won't go that far these
days right let's make it ten billion
dollars and I'm not gonna like say you
can't see any other people that you care
about but for any one of those people
that you really do genuinely care about
let's say right now I could make you a
cash offer and say I will give you ten
million dollars if you will from this
point on have nothing to do with that
person ever again
it'll be a tough dilemma I think for a
lot of people because those are genuine
goods oh no you know and I'm not saying
that all of you because you're
hesitating you it you know you're a bad
person or you don't value your friends
highly that is something that actually
should be a tough dilemma because ten
million dollars can buy an off
a lot of good things but the
relationship with the person that you
care about is also a primary good
something that makes you happy
that's fulfilling maybe the money
couldn't satisfy that maybe you know now
the money could help you with that if
you want to take your friend out for for
dinner or for coffee and you'd go up to
the counter to pay you say I don't have
any money they say well we don't have
any food for you any coffee for you get
out of here go somewhere else want to
take your friend to a concert that
requires money to write a lot of things
that require money but those things
themselves tend to be goods that go
beyond mirror move off one of those
goods that that capitalist is interested
in is good character and he says
something really interesting he says
when you get older and you need both of
these in order to be happy you need
wealth in part because you you won't be
happy without wealth you know if you're
poor all the ages gonna be tough but you
also need a good character why well
let's think about this this is going a
little bit beyond what he talks about
but are there ways to screw up your life
with money one of the ways that you can
think of breaking right off the bat yeah
yeah you could
especially if she started getting into
debt to people that's that's a pretty
yeah that's a pretty soft destructive
way you know Odette
yeah
not managing one's money well to stay
within one's means of them going further
and further into debt the debt starts to
take on a life of its own right some of
you may have experienced this with
things like credit cards or cargo things
along those lines at this point it's not
hard to wind up you know in ten thousand
twenty thousand dollars with the debt
through just mismanaging a few things
over the period of a year or two years
all I imagine a lot of you have student
loans to write and student loan debt can
you know let's say you say oh I'm just
not gonna repay that that live
repercussions right a lot more nowadays
there's a lot more than rules about that
for you than they did for my parents
generation my generation and we're kind
of you know in the middle what are other
ways people script their lives with
money let's say you don't go into debt
you don't get hooked on drugs is
everything a-okay
so you come out with nothing and then
all you've done is it is diminished the
money that you had I'm thinking more
about ways in which people make their
lives worse yeah I think that sometimes
having not valuing what you have
sometimes okay get back down there for
example I hope yeah I don't see the
little people because you have money no
I have money so what do I you know what
what is it matter that they don't have
money yeah that's that's not interesting
I mean they're sort of starts to live
you know if you have if you have money
there are certain situations where you
can walk into and you automatically have
power over people and if you use that
power badly they can start to you know
affect your character and I'll do it
over time think about it have any of you
ever worked in retail industries or
servers the restaurants do you have any
horror stories about awful patrons to
all of you have horror stories about
awful patrons yeah you know why because
there's some people exactly what you're
describing who walk in it because they
have money and because that person is
there to serve them they you know say
I'm gonna do whatever I want and you
better you know give in to me that's
that's a way to develop bad character
that good character
oh yeah we're not even just that for
people who had nothing and made their
way sort of forget where they came from
because now they have this wealth is
affluence and they I remember that they
were from the Bronx that they they
always live in Westchester okay that's
that's a good example to you know
Socrates says something to capitalist
that's really interesting I said when
he's asking did you make your own money
he says you know those who make their
own money they almost treat it as if
it's like their children you know they
love it even more than those who just
inherited it because you know they it's
part of who they they are and maybe
that's that's a mistake somebody else
did their hand up but when you're
purchasing decisions could you like buy
a whole bunch of crazy stuff that's
that's you know not going to be good for
you if you can you use money to I mean
we talked about drugs that would
definitely fit that case what if we
spend all your money on CDs and you
never use it on but I had friends who
like what they have like 4,000 CDs then
you'd walk in and be like this is your
this is your whole set of possessions
right this way your cars is broken down
and why you never have any money for
anything we didn't you gonna play all
4,000 of these
I just like to him
like he's supported for your 6040
decision group of friends yeah I'm
liking some devil complex but he pays
them right to further okay well that's
interesting because we would look at
that on one way it's like a good action
right because he's taking care of
somebody else on the other hand if you
just give somebody money we see this a
lot with with kids of people right just
give a money no strings attached so long
as they they like you know kiss off to
you or something like that every once in
a while often times that ruins our
character doesn't makes them dependent
they don't want to work for themselves
but he feels like if he doesn't do it
he's a bad person that's interesting
yeah one second you know when we look at
Arizona he's gonna say how much wealth
do you actually need and and he actually
thinks that you need enough for your
family not just for you but also for
those
like on the one hand it seems like a
good action because it's not taking care
of her own yeah
risk I mean I've seen what kinda feel
when that stops but it's coming so right
but the other thing is this I work in a
group home for kids that have been in my
in my program has been for lack of a
better term institutionalized sure
because they've been in the system for
so long and what ends up happening is
because they have been catered to their
every need by the system they buy their
clothes their giving that are by their
shelter everything yeah as they get
older they start to
develop this sense of entitlement you
owe this to me
yeah so if you stop we're gonna have a
problem
because you owe it to me to make sure
that I have a coat even though I gave my
coat to my friend because I felt like it
yeah so you got to get me another one if
you don't I'm gonna rip the place up
yeah yeah so sort of just to recap here
what kept us is saying Socrates seems to
be endorsing this too is these are both
needed and they kind of reinforce each
other it's not enough just to have
wealth wealth is not a bad thing but
it's not enough to have wealth you
actually need some sort of good
character to structure what you do with
your wealth to structure how you manage
it such as a matter either two of like
you know is it going to make you richer
to be a good person maybe maybe not what
you actually have and what you do with
it it's going to depend very much on
your character